[Music]
hey there was a big premiere last night
this one all the way across the pond in
England for the world war two epic
Dunkirk or as we call the event when
Harry Met Harry
[Music]
it's pretty exciting it was pop royalty
meeting the real deal when Harry Styles
met Prince Harry on the red carpet what
did these two talk about maybe it was
something like this yes would you like
to do some more acting as well as
singing yeah I mean I was I feel very
lucky to have been in this one and I
really thought too much further ahead
than that but I would given the choice I
would absolutely do this one again yes
Steve Styles has been rethinking doing
more movies I'm leaning towards focusing
on his music I don't know I enjoyed this
I might be one undone though I'd do this
one again so passionate about veteran
causes the Prince also met with men who
fought for Britain in World War two
and while Prince Harry is in England his
love mega Markel is in Toronto back on
the set of her TV show suits I'm worried
about how he's doing after last night
this week she celebrated the show's
100th episode and et has learned from a
source on the set the actress now has a
security guard with her at all times and
her own private driver which wasn't the
case before she dated the Prince that's
not very specific
[Music]
you